Muhammad is greater than Jesus.
>> No, not according to the Quran, Muhammad
is under the feet of Jesus.
>> That's not true.
>> You want to bet? Okay. You want me to
prove it to you? In the Quran, who's the
greatest woman Allah created?
>> Mary.
>> Say it again.
>> Oh, so Jesus's mother is the greatest
woman and yet Muhammad is greater than
Jesus.
>> According to Sah Muslim, where is
Muhammad's mother?
>> Muhammad's mother died when he was
>> Where is Amina? According Muslim, I have
the hadith right here.
What do you mean? Where is she? She she
died.
>> Where is his mother and father? Your
prophet said there.
>> Who said that?
>> Your prophet said his father's and when
your prophet went to pray for his
mother, Allah said do not pray for her
forgiveness.
>> Where does he say that?
>> I'm going to say it to you. So I'm going
to now use the Quran to show that
Muhammad is under the feet of Jesus
because you said he's greater than
Jesus. He's not good enough to lick
Jesus's sandals. But I'm going to show
it to you from your Quran. I'm not even
going to use the Bible. Let me get you
the hadith. Okay. Your prophet was
weeping because when he went to the
grave of his mother, he asked Allah to
forgive her and he said, "Do not ask for
her forgiveness." And then he told
another man, "My father, Abdullah, and
your father are in hell." Okay. Well,
let me show it to you.
>> They probably were.
>> They what?
>> I said Muhammad's father probably was.
>> Uh, and what about his mother?
>> Possibly.
>> Okay. So, wait. You just told me
Muhammad is greater than Jesus. And yet
Jesus's mother is the greatest woman
that Allah created. Why?
>> Because she had this birth.
>> What does the birth have to do with Mary
becoming the greatest of all women?
>> Without Jesus, Mary's not great.
>> Thank you. You just buried yourself.
Yeah. Sue.
>> In other words, because of Jesus, Mary
became the greatest. Well, the only way
she can be the greatest if he's the
greatest. Thank you, Sue. I see what
you're saying. I see from
>> you got it now.
>> I see where you're coming from.
>> Uh, no, you just I used your logic. What
was your logic? Your logic was
>> Yeah, but Muhammad is greater.
>> Jesus made Mary,
but Muhammad made his mother an
inhabitant of So Muhammad made his
parents.
>> So let's go with your logic.
>> So his parents died by the time he was
six.
>> What has that got to do with anything?
Why didn't Allah do for Muhammad what he
did for Jesus?
>> Why he did?
>> Here's aith. Why didn't Allah do for
Muhammad what he did for Isa? Why didn't
he make Amina a believer and the
greatest of all women?
>> Because
>> because what?
>> They lived in a pagan.
>> No, because according to your hadith,
there were the like
they knew the path because they knew
about Christianity and Judaism. Don't
give me that garbage. doesn't work.
>> There are pagans.
>> Doesn't matter. Why didn't Allah guide
her like he guided
to the right path? Because even before
Muhammad according to your Islamic
tradition, the hunatha, they were there
before Muhammad and they were guided on
the right dean and they renounced
paganism. Why didn't your god do that
for Amina like he did it for Jesus's
mother?
What?
>> Who's the hunafhat? The hunafar.
the people who found the correct dean
before Muhammad in your
when confirm Muhammad wasn't
demonpossessed it says she took him to
her cousin
who in the days of Jahyah became a
Christian and wrote the gospel and he
confirmed that Amus came to him and it
says in your tradition there was a group
of them the hunafa who left the paganism
of the Cabba and followed the true dean.
So why didn't Allah do that for
Muhammad's mother?
>> What was the true dean?
>> Following the path of the prophets, not
the idolatry of the pagans. I just
explained it to you.
>> Yeah.
>> Answer the question. Why didn't he do
that for Amina?
>> I don't know. That's a question you're
going to have to
>> because Muhammad is under the feet of
Jesus. Because I'm going to go by your
logic, your words. I'm gonna show you
that. Let's go by. reason the only
reason why I say Jesus is lesser than
Muhammad is for two things.
>> We we believe Muhammad is the most
beloved to God. That's the one.
>> That's a lie from the pit of hell.
>> Okay. I'm just saying that's what we
believe. And the second thing is
uh Prophet Muhammad is actually going to
be the only prophet out of all the
prophets to uh to take away from our bad
deeds or not take away from our bad
deeds. That's a lie from the pit of
hell. Just because you think he told you
that means nothing because what I'm
showing you is Muhammad is under the
feet of Jesus from the Quran. Now let me
show you here. Here's hadith Muslim.
Just listen. Be patient man
>> because you said Muhammad is greater
than Jesus which is the most blasphemous
thing you can say in light of the way he
lived. But let's go with here. Sah
Muslim I gave you the link. Abu Hura
reported the apostle of Allah visited
the grave of his mother and he wept and
he wept and moved others around him to
tears and said I sought permission from
my lord to beg forgiveness of her
but it was not granted to me I begged
Allah oh Allah forgive my mother he said
no and this is the most beloved to Allah
making him cry at the fact that his
mother died and he didn't forgive her
and I sought permission to visit her
grave and it was granted to me so visit
the graves for that makes you Mindful of
death. This is Sah Muslim. Here's the
link. I'm going to show it to you. So, I
want to repeat your words. It's
recorded. The reason why Mary's the
greatest is because Jesus made her
great. Well, if she's the greatest woman
cuz Jesus, that means he must be the
greatest man. But your prophet Muhammad
couldn't even make his parents great
because they're in hell. According to
Bkar here and Muslim, here's Muslim.
There it is.
>> He was a kid when they died.
>> Buddy, you don't you don't get it. Let
me repeat it again. Maybe it's not clear
the first 10 times. So what he could
have guided Amina and Abdullah to be
godfearing.
He could have saved them out of paganism
like he did before your prophet became a
prophet. Why did he do that for them?
Yeah. You have no answer. It's okay.
Nobody
>> because Muhammad is nothing in
comparison to Jesus. But now let me show
you where his father is. You want to see
where his father is?
Who's
>> Muhammad's father?
Here you go. Muhammad's father. Here you
go. This is the link right there. I'm
going to put in private chat. This is
from Muslim website, not mine. It's Sahi
Muslim.
Sah Muslim again. And I'm going to play
Asim Alhim
about Muhammad's parents being in hell.
He's a Salafi Muslim who loves Muhammad.
I'm going to play him now. Just hold on.
Anas reported, "Verily a person said,
Messenger of Allah, where is my father?"
He said, "He is in the fire." When he
turned away, he called him and said,
"Verily, my father and your father are
in the fire." So Muhammad said, "My
father is in hell and my mother's in
hell." Now, can I play Asim Hakeim
saying your prophet's parents are in
hell and they had no excuse because they
knew about the true dean?
>> Yeah. No. I I mean that's
>> Can I play him though? I want to hear
him.
>> Okay.
>> I like when he says it better than I say
it because he does a good job.
>> Want to hear somebody else say it.
>> No, he's a Muslim. He's a Salafi. He's
got a show where he answers question.
Here it is. He's He's not a joke.
>> Just can I want to play Hakeim? Hakeim
prophet parents.
>> Yeah, but I mean what's the
>> Well, I want to hear. Look, see this
patient's going to kill you. I want the
Christians to hear your one of your
Muslim scholars admitting your
Muhammad's parents are in hell. Here it
is. Are we ready?
Here.
Here it goes.
Fourth question
is why are the parents of the prophetam
in hell?
This question you do not ask me about.
Listen,
>> this question is something that the
prophet himself
told us about and the hadith is in
Muslim
>> question sorry
>> his father is
>> a man came to him and said oh prophet of
Allah where is my father so the prophet
saidam your father is in hell how did
the prophet know
because Allah told him so the man did
not feel well about the answer. The
prophet said to him, "Your father and my
father are in hell."
And another hadith, the prophet wept one
day, so they asked him, "Why are you
weeping?" He said, "I sought permission
from Allah to seek forgiveness from my
mother and he denied me from seeking
forgiveness for her." Which means that
in accordance to the ayah in surah Toba
that
the prophet and the believers are not
permitted to seek forgiveness for those
who died on idol worshiing even if they
were next of kin end of story. Now this
was the prophet's
fatwah
not minewa
>> not sheh x y z it was from the prophet
himself and it's not in a dubious book
it's in
Muslim
>> the most authentic book alongside with
the bkari after the Quran so why this is
not our issue or problem
because this is from allahel it's the
revelation. You can say that maybe
because the people of Mecca had the
religion of Ibraim.
>> Did you hear it? He's now going to
refute you. Listen to your scholar. They
had no excuse to be idoltors because
they knew the religion of Abraham. They
could have embraced it. Listen. Look
what he's going to say. Listen, not me.
>> Why? They were performing Hajj. They
were doing and they had the original
religion of Ibraim of worshiping Allah
on and his son is
their forefather
and there was the religion of Judaism
and Christianity which they had could
have adopted anyone. So these religion
of montheism were there
>> but they failed to choose it. So those
who failed to choose it would end up in
hell. This might be a reason I don't
know. What I know is what the prophet
said to us. We have to believe and
comply and Allah know.
>> So he just refuted your excuse. He said
they knew about the religion of Abraham.
They could embrace it. And there was
Judaism in Christianity. They could
embrace it. They chose not to. And the
fatwa of your prophet is his mother's in
hell and his father is in hell. But
Jesus's mother is the greatest woman
your God created. It's that and you're
still trying to tell me Muhammad is
greater than Jesus. God forbid such
blasphemy.